when evening falls in the village of
saman Kong Julius majuro and his sister
Janina head to their other job teaching
julia started the school 10 years ago
when it turns cold shepherds leave the
mountains for pastures close to the
school students here learned basic
skills I want to teach them so to maths
and English and also some skills we also
want to help them to call socially
because they have been isolated so they
used to be alone they need someone to
encourage them and also to cancel them
drinking what about during the day these
boys tend to their cattle and cheap they
can only be here in the evening while
their animals are safe in their pens ya
know I come to this school because I
cannot read or write I realized that
this is the only place where i can get
help and education hidro to the boys are
happy to see each other again the school
ends at 10pm after dinner they return to
their flocks many of them have to walk
for hours through the night Julius
became a shepherd at 14 his family was
poor so he looked after a local farmers
animals after one year the farmer gave
Julius six sheep enough to help him go
to school today Julius is a farmer
himself he isn't paid to teach but he's
happy to help others no matter how but
my passion is just to help people
because for my side I think we are on F
on people's we are not here by mistake
and we have something specific to do on
earth that's my my my intention that's
why I want to invest in my life to the
Shepherd many boys turned to shepherding
to support their families but ley lo
hanno llama salsa has different plans he
is one of Julius's students and wants to
work in the city for him the toughest
part in the mountain
is the loneliness you're not the way and
I will baby anything it was painful to
leave my parents because we don't even
have the means to speak to one another
johanna Luella wanna have a way
sometimes we can call each other on a
mobile phone Mahalo it's tough and it's
a long journey home yeah a young guy
little italy our hope is just to develop
this country because this is a very very
very very poor country maybe next time
on next two or three years coming there
will be a difference from the ship and
the villagers say the shepherds in this
area can now read and write more than
500 boys have gone through Julius's
school he's most proud of those who went
on to graduate from regular schools